My dad asked for muffins last night
as we were closing up the kitchen after dinner,
so I prepared a batter of primitive wheat flour
and allowed it to ferment while we slept.
In the morning, while brewing my coffee,
I threw together the batter in one big bowl.
I sweetened them with just two tablespoons of coconut sugar.
My mom had brought some oversized zucchinis
that I last picked from the farm,
so I figured this would be a great way to use them.
The batter is stiff, which I want,
and a wooden spoon does the job to mix everything together nicely.
We had some wild blueberries in the freezer,
so I folded these in last
and then greased the muffin pan with coconut oil.
Using 1/4 cup measuring utensil,
I carefully distributed the muffin batter into 12 cups
and then placed in a preheated 425 degree Fahrenheit oven.
The temperature is reduced to 375 after 7 minutes.
The final result, after another 18 minutes,
is decadent muffins with crispy,
slightly brown tops and moist centers.
Breakfast was served with cast iron fried eggs and warm muffins
fresh out of the oven. My parents,
the kids, Eric, and I all sat around the table to enjoy what we had.